The Islamic State of Iraq and Syria is a phenomenon
so terrible and shocking it seems impossible.
It controls an area the size of the United
Kingdom, commits mass atrocities, and launches
terror attacks abroad.
To understand ISIS, it helps to tell the story
of its rise.
That story begins far away and many years
before ISIS existed.
In 1979 the Soviet Union invades Afghanistan
to defend a puppet dictator against rebels.
Young men from the MidEast flock to join the
rebels.
Many see it as a religious struggle, and some
develop extremist views.
Among them is a well-educated young Saudi
named Osama bin Laden.
Also in Afghanistan is a semi-literate former
street thug from Jordan named Abu Musab Zarqawi.
They do not get along, and never will, but
will create the groups we today know as al-Qaeda
and as ISIS.
The Soviets withdraw in 1989 and the Arab
fighters return home.
Bin Laden grows al-Qaeda into a global network,
to continue the struggle against Islam's enemies.
Zarqawi forms his own group, but it fizzles.
Both men later return to Afghanistan, now
ruled by the Taliban.
On September 11, 2001, al-Qaeda attacks America
from its base there.
The US invades Afghanistan and bin Laden flees
to Pakistan.
Zarqawi, still obscure, flees to a remote
and lawless corner of Iraq.
Two years later, the US does something that
will transform the Middle East and set the
stage for ISIS: it invades Iraq.
The Americans topple Saddam Hussein's secular,
Sunni dictatorship and disbands the Iraqi
army.
Thousands of Sunni Iraqi soldiers, angry and
unemployed, join the insurgency.
Jihadist groups, also Sunni, see this as a
repeat of the Soviet invasion of Afghanistan,
and again flood in to fight.
Zarqawi is among them.
Zarqawi's group becomes Iraq's most ruthless.
He especially attacks Shia, Iraq's majority,
deliberately sparking a Sunni-Shia civil war.
By 2004, Zarqawi is a jihadist superstar.
Al-Qaeda, isolated and weakened, attempts
to bolster its image by forming an alliance
with Zarqawi's group, which becomes known
as al-Qaeda in Iraq.
But in 2006, Iraq's Sunnis rise up against
Zarqawi, and the US kills him in an air strike.
Over the next few years al-Qaeda in Iraq is
largely defeated.
The Americans withdraw in 2011 from an Iraq
that finally looks stable.
In 2011, the Arab Spring spreads across the
Middle East.
In Syria, Bashar al-Assad cracks down violently
on protesters.
They eventually fire back, leading to civil
war.
Assad fears the world will intervene against
him.
So he releases jihadists en masse from Syrian
prisons, tinging the rebels with extremism
and making it harder for foreigners to back
them.
Back in Iraq, what little remains of Zarqawi's
group is still allied with al-Qaeda but now
known as the Islamic State in Iraq.
It's led by a bookish religious scholar who
calls himself Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi.
In early 2012, Baghdadi sends a top deputy
to Syria to start a new al-Qaeda branch to
fight alongside the rebels: Jabhat al-Nusra.
Baghdadi also attacks a series of prisons
in Iraq.
They free former jihadists and recruit new
ones, growing stronger.
In April 2013, Baghdadi announces he is taking
control of all al-Qaeda-allied forces in Syria
and Iraq.
His group expands into Syria, becoming the
Islamic State of Iraq and Syria, or ISIS.
Al-Qaeda rejects Baghdadi's power grab and,
in 2014, formally exiles him.
The two jihadist groups, long at odds, are
now at war.
ISIS grows powerful in Syria, in part because
Assad tolerates its rise, which he does because
it divides his enemies within Syria, and foreign
powers are too focused on ISIS now to worry
about Assad.
By June 2014, ISIS has built an army in Syria,
and it launches a military-style invasion
into Iraq.
The Iraqi army, weakened by corruption, folds
with little fight.
Many Sunnis are tired of their Shia-dominated
and increasingly authoritarian government,
and welcome or at least tolerate ISIS's arrival.
Within days, ISIS controls a third of Iraq
and a big part of Syria.
ISIS's goal is more audacious than anything
imagined by al-Qaeda: to revive the ancient
Caliphate and expand it to encompass all Muslims.
It earnestly believes its holy war will then
bring about the apocalypse as foretold in
scripture.
Thousands of Muslims, mostly from the Middle
East and from Europe, flock to join the group.
Some join for religious reasons, but many
are just disillusioned or angry, and feel
that ISIS offers them answers and a purpose.
ISIS quickly overreaches.
That August, it invades Kurdish territory
in Iraq and Syria, sparking counter-attacks
from better-organized Kurdish forces.
It launches a genocide against Iraqi Yazidis
and murders the American journalist James
Foley on camera, outraging the world and provoking
an American-led air campaign against it.
ISIS is unable to withstand the onslaught,
and loses more than a fifth of its territory.
In response, it begins launching increasingly
spectacular terror attacks abroad: Kuwait
City, Sinai, Beirut, Sousse and then Paris.
So-called lone wolves inspired by ISIS propaganda
also launch attacks, though they're often
amateurish and less effective.
Eventually, ISIS will lose its state.
It is simply too weak, has no allies or outside
funders, and is surrounded by enemies.
But ISIS will respond by reverting to what
it was before, as AQI: an insurgency and a
terror group still capable of horrifying violence.
In that form, it could be around for years.